[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui fait que l'on aime un
endroit plus qu'un autre qu'est-ce qui
fait que nous choisissons un itinéraire
plutôt qu'un autre sans en être
obligatoirement conscient nos choix ne
relèvent pas uniquement des aspects
pratiques fonctionnels ou esthétiques
nous entretenons des rapports
particuliers avec des endroits où nous
nous sentons bien ici à tour nous
rencontrons Georg Henry Laffond
chercheur géographe il travaille sur ces
questions avec une équipe
pluridisciplinaire en premier lieu un
paysage est-il vu de la même manière par
tous on construit un paysage en fonction
de ce qu'on est
euh parce qu'on a envie enfin parce que
chacun va vraiment y mettre ce qui
compte pour lui derrière il y a des
choses qui peuvent être partagées ça
difficile devant une montagne devant la
mer de pas y voir des choses qu'on
partage tous ce soit parce que c'est
notre fond culturel parce que s'il y a
des images qui sont tellement fortes
qu'elles nous imprègnent ou parce qu'il
y a une idéologie qui est tellement
forte qui a été véhiculée qu'elle nous
marque mais c'est vraiment une rencontre
pour moi une rencontre d'état d'âme
c'està dire j'arrive avec mon mon Patos
j'arrive avec mon humeur et je vais
pouvoir voir d'ici les choses 25 fois
mais j'aurai jamais la même vision là il
y a 2 minutes ce qui m'a frappé c'est
que j'y voyais la prou d'un navire c'est
facile c'est évident il y a de l'eau
c'est si c'est une île on peut laffiler
l'image mais c'était vraiment ça quelque
chose qui avance et qui qui rentre ben
d'un coup là ça me paraît moins évident
au bout de 5 minutes ainsi notre vision
serait influencée par nos émotions
agissant comme un filtre colorant le
monde environnant suivant nos humeurs
Georg Henry habite tour de depuis 4 ans
comme chacun petit à petit il s'est créé
ses repères ses lieux et pour illustrer
ses travaux de recherche il nous emmène
vers l'îleocar un de ses lieux favoris
là je lui demande si ce lieu lui permet
de se poser poser moi je dirais qu'il me
procure une certaine sécurité c'estàdire
une sécurité je m'y sens bien
physiquement mon corps se sent bien
enfin j'interprète ça comme mon corps se
sent bien et puis je me sens appaisé
quand je réfléchis sur sur ce que je
suis où je vais et cetera les choses que
j'ai envie de faire les choses que j'ai
perdu les choses que que je rêve et
cetera ce que j'ai raté enfin la vie de
tout le monde au final tout ce qu'on
fait dans notre vie cet endroit là il me
permet d'être en sécurité permet de
regarder tout ça d'une manière assez
calme donc oui je me sens bien
ici on mène une une recherche qui qui
s'intitule urbafect sur différentes
villes de de la région Centre on
interroge les gens avec une question
toute simple qu'est-ce que vous faites
là au final c'estàdire ben écrivez-nous
votre histoire et racontez-nous votre
histoire et on va essayer de décortiquer
de ce qui est du lieu de ce qui qui est
de l'individu et ce qui est au final de
cette relation individu lieu en
décortiquant apparaissent des liens sans
nous en rendre compte nous interprétons
et choisissons nos lieux de prédilection
en fonction de notre bagage passé
présent ce que nous cherchons ce que
nous fuyons ce que nous projetons sur
notre futur ce lieu là ici moi je lui
donne un sens dans on va pas dire dans
trois directions ça serait trop simple
mais à trois niveaux c'està-dire il y a
effectivement une direction c'est mon
existence je suis né un endroit je sais
pas où je vais mourir et puis c'est
passé ça donc il a ce sens là parce
qu'il prend une place il y a une
sensation charnelle quand je dis charnel
ça peut être aussi bien voilà c'est
c'est l'essence wolfactif mais c'est
charnel c'est mes pieds c'est mes mains
et puis il y a la signification
c'estàdire ça une vraie signification ce
lieu
[Musique]
là petit à petit les bruits de la ville
s'éloigne le verre remplit de plus en
plus notre champ de vision les odeurs
changent notre sensib au lieu est aussi
épidermique car c'est par nos C sens que
nous appréhendons notre environnement
pour Georg Henri chacun d'entre nous a
besoin de ces lieux où l'on peut laisser
l'esprit vagabonder et organiser un
retour sur
soi ils attendent quelque chose du
territoire et quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre de l'attention comme on peut
attendreun personne au final enfin c'est
c'est comme ça qu'on peut l'interpréter
mais c'est ces mots là dire prenez soin
de moi permettez-moi de faire ce que je
semble bon de faire ici et ailleurs
c'est-à-dire là c'est très bien j'ai ce
qu'il me faut au final j'ai ce qu'il
faut cette approche sensible du paysage
et du lien que nous tissons avec a
jusqu'àors été ignoré ou peu prise en
compte elle est pourtant une composante
essentielle à nos vies et pourrait sans
doute enrichir l'action des
professionnel du
[Musique]
paysage